are you ready to see Priscilla with all
the buzz surrounding Sophia kappa's
Priscilla Presley biopic we're all
wondering what really went on behind the
scenes and how these stars were able to
embody their iconic characters so well
luckily they're more than happy to share
their experiences casting actors for a
biopic about stars that everyone knows
is never easy the actors have to be not
only talented but they need to be
capable of transforming into a real
person both looking the part and fitting
the vibe there was a lot that director
Sophia had to think about when casting
Elvis and Priscilla Presley before she
landed on Jacob elordi and kayy spany as
for Priscilla the years of her life that
take place in the film span from her
early teens to her 30s I really wanted
one actress to play Priscilla and she
had to play from 14 to 29 she had many
fans in the biz who recommended her to
Copa he has this baby face she can pass
for 15 and she's just so thoughtful and
um I knew that she would approach this
with sensitivity it's clear that cppo
was confident that kayy was the woman
for the job now as for Elvis the rules
requirements were a bit different the
idea of Elvis is so daunting nobody
looks like Elvis he's such a big
character and it was really important to
me to not have a character CH still
Jacob managed to fit this very specific
bill and when I met Jacob I felt like he
has that just a Charisma and the feeling
that I could feel that he pulled us off
and be a teen heart th and that had the
sensitivity to show this other side of
him kppa did a perfect job casting these
difficult to cast roles with Kaye and
Jacob allori but the leads acting skills
weren't all it took to make these
Transformations complete for the first
time as Elvis and Priscilla together on
set and it was just as much fun for all
Lordi to see himself put on the Elvis
costume for the first time he FaceTime
my mom immediately and and my agent and
I I think it was this I was like it was
totally ego still all Lord's
transformation into the king of rock and
roll went beyond the costume if you want
to see like an Elvis impersonator you
can you can go to Vegas it was about
catching the the essence of this person
the biggest thing for me was trying to
identify and find where the human being
was under all the glitz and the gold and
the and the voice and the caricatures it
was surprising however to see the small
ways that costumes hair and makeup made
the actors feel like their characters
for me it was down to when I would we
had all the jewelry from the estate and
it would be when I'd sort of clasp the
ID bracelet or put the Horseshoe ring on
it was like the kind of final touches
these details had a different kind of
effect on Kaye there were times when I
had that beehive on where I'm like I
actually can't move any other way than
this I don't really have any other
options in these heels so it definitely
informed a lot of how I H myself so it's
safe to say that the costuming
department made quite a difference in
how these characters were portrayed when
Jacob walked in in The Comeback Special
the leather suit we were all like oh
yeah that's not all that made the
Transformations work though for Kaye
meeting with Priscilla Presley herself
made a major difference Priscilla was
very gracious with her time we met in
Los Angeles first time we met we ended
up talking for about 4 hours so um just
tried to sort of sit back and see how
much she felt comfortable telling me
luckily Priscilla was very open with
Kaye and this helped her in her betrayal
just being in front of her and in her
presence was so informative and how I I
played uh tried to do my own version of
her story and if meeting with Priscilla
Presley to accurately tell her story
wasn't enough she also watched the movie
for the first time while sitting next to
her cie called this absolutely surreal
it's clear that Priscilla Presley felt
the same herself according to her it's
very difficult to sit and watch a film
about you about your life about your
love she was eager to help though she
said Sophia did an amazing job she did
her homework we spoke a couple of times
and I really put everything out for her
that I could Priscilla knew right away
that she trusted cppa with the job of
course I was never going to say no your
whole family actually so talented and
knows you know knows how to tell the
story and cppa took this unusually
difficult task seriously for me it was
such a big responsibility to tell her
story in a way that she would feel good
about it now I was also thinking about
something that represented her in a way
that felt accurate to her as far as
prisilla was concerned though cppa
pulled it off and I was really so
relieved and it meant so much to me when
she saw the film and said um this that's
what my life was like Elvis's biopic
Elvis premiered less than a year before
Priscilla so of course there was some
stiff competition for Jacob all Lordi
who was coming up against Austin
Butler's popular portrayal of the star
in Elvis luckily this didn't intimidate
allori there's no real space to to be
daunted or afraid it's one of those
things you hear I think from actors all
the time that you want um you want a
challenge and um you know this certainly
was was it it's easy to see why allori
wasn't intimidated by any prior
portrayals of Elvis he managed to pull
the roll off perfectly and there was
quite a bit of work that went into it I
mean there's a lot of uh boring boring
hours and stories of homework really is
what it is there was a lot of
information to kind of rival through
still it's clear that this was some
homework that he loved doing just a ton
of research but it was all it was all a
joy cuz you're really like listening to
some of the best music in the world uh
watching some absolute Classic Movies
it's clear that the actors couldn't have
pulled it off without director Sophia
cppa I was uh really really lucky to be
working with Sophia who kind of put my
FES immediately and she managed to bring
the Presley's story to life it's kind of
what the world that Sophia built CAD
towards was finding a truth that hasn't
been seen before taking opening the door
to graceand and inventing from fact what
we thought the the real people might
have spoken like do you think these
famous faces were well cast was it right
for Jacob a Lordi not to be intimidated
by the Rival Elvis let's discuss it in
the comments and for more videos like
this one be sure to like And subscribe
to the
things